Çok
[Müzik]
teşekkür ederim
Merhabalar Hoş geldiniz Bu pandemi
döneminde yüz yüze e her ne kadar
aramızda maskeler olsa da bir arada
olabilmek Gerçekten güzel
maskeleri pandemi döneminde giydik
fiziksel olarak girdik hayatımızın
birçok döneminde belki doğduğumuz andan
itibaren içimizde çeşitli maskeler var
Bunları fark etmeye görmemeye temas
etmeye çalışırız antibi döneminde çok
farklı bir şey oldu hepimiz Ee Çünkü
İnsanoğlu ölümlü olduğunu bilip buna
rağmen Bu yan tek Varlık ve bu bilgiyle
yaşamak gerçekten zor arkadaşlar ve bu
bilgiyle yaşamanın yolu Ancak o bilgiyi
inkar ederek unutarak yaşamak hiç yokmuş
gibi
kuvvetle birlikte pandemi döneminde bize
olan şey bilgi bize çok sert
hatırlatıldı ve her an her yerden
gelemeyeceğim her şekilde olabileceğiz
ve en yakınlarımız dahil
evladımız anne babamız
kardeşimizden sakınır uzak durur bir
seviyede kendimizi korumamız gereken
fiziksel bir mesafe lenme ihtiyacı
içerisinde olduk
Peki bu birçok dengeyi bozdu Birçok
psikolojik olarak gerçek yaşantımızda
algılarımızı yaşam şeklimizi günlük
rutin lerimizi değiştirdi ancak iç
dünyamızda
çok daha farklı hareketler olmaya
başladı neler oldu neler yaşıyoruz Biraz
onları konuşmak istiyorum tabii ki
pandemi dönemiyle birlikte gerçek bir
korku gerçek bir tehdit ve bu gerçek
tehdide karşı bir savunma siper lenme ve
maske kullanmayı ihtiyacımız oldu bu
şekilde kendimizi koruma altına aldık
Ancak bu maskeleri yaparken evlerimize
kapandık sosyal hattımızdan uzaklaştık
sahip olduğumuz rolleri yaşamdaki
duruşumuzu varoluşu muzu geri çekmek ve
farklı bir tarzda yaşamak ve yeniden
dizayn etmek zorunda kaldık bunu
yaparken dünyadan Bize gelen uyaranlar
kendi içimizdeki sesleri durup
dinlememiz e İzin vermeyen Öyle bir
zaman tanımayan dış yaşantıdan mahrum
kaldığımız da içimizdeki nevrotik
anksiyete lerin kaygıların dışa çıkacağı
ol o koca bir durumla karşı karşıya
kaldık Arkadaşlar bu dönemde Onun için
çok fazla kişi Terapiye ihtiyacı
Terapiye gitmek kendini anlama kendi ile
ilgili bir takım meseleleri olduğunu
fark edecek zaman bulduk Çünkü
içimizdeki anksiyeteleri çoğunlukla
görmezden gelir temas etmez maskeler
örteriz Dış dünyada işlevsel
etkileşimsel
çeşitli taleplerimize çeşitli
ihtiyaçlarımızı var olacağımız alanlar
yaratmaya çalışırız Tabii ki bunu
yaratırken
shano dünyanın akıyor olması gerekir
dünyanın durduğu bir noktada İç dünya
durmuyor iç Dünyamız her zaman aktif her
zaman arar her zaman sorar ve bize ait
olmayan
bizim doğamızda olmayan maskele
dediğimiz örttüğümüz her şey bir gün
çıkabilmek kendini anlayabilmek
anlatabilmek ve ifade edebilmenin yolunu
şu an sitelerimiz kaygılarımız
çoğunlukla bunlarla örüntülü dür
arkadaşlar bunları ifade eder bize
kendimizi bulmanın kendimizi farklı
şekilde var etmenin Dışarıdan aldığımız
bilgilerle donanımlardan ziyade
içimizdeki özümüzü ifade etmenin yolunu
arayacak Yollar bulmaya çalışırız bir
yandan çoğunlukla bunları örteriz
bunlarla baş etmenin en iyi yolu Onları
maskelemek örtmektir Çünkü orada bize
ait olanlar çoğunlukla kişisel bireysel
duygulanım larımız dır ve bu
duygulanımlar genellikle pozitif
duygulanımlar çok olan kabul edilip çok
kaydeder alınmaz içimizde kalan
örttüğümüz yerler zayıflık larımız
kırılganlık larımız hassasiyet lerimizi
ve çözülmemiş duygusal yaşantılarımız
bir tanışalım çok güzel ifade etti bu
dönemde hayat bu varoluşu ve Hayatın
kendisi yaşam içerisinde olmak yaşayan
biri olmakla ilgili dertlerini
anlatırken konuştuğumuz çeşitli
süreçlerde şunu çok güzel ifade etti çok
incelikli bir şekilde Meral Hanım
sanıyorum ki ben sizinle ertelenmiş
zayıflıklarımı konuşmak istiyorum bunu
söylemek çok zor ama birine söylemem
gerekiyor artık konuşmam gerekiyor
içimde taşıyamıyorum birçoğumuzun
içimizde
ertelemeye çalıştık larımız çalıştığımız
sayı flık larımız ve acılarımız var
aslında bunları ortaya çıkarabilmek
bunları anlamak anlamlandırmak ve
yeniden yapılandırmak üzere ilerleye
bildiğimiz noktada hayat bize çok şey
sunar hayatın bize sunduğu şey
arkadaşlar statü kariyer başarı
ulaştığımız dış dünyadaki
kazanmak dışında esastır
ve kendimize olan
kazanımdır kendi varoluşumuz a duygusal
dünyamızda bu acılarımızı ifade edecek
dindirecek dönüştürecek onlara rağmen
rahat ve mutlu şekilde kendimizi ifade
edecek alanlar yaratabilme becerisi son
derece Engin ve keyifli bir yerdir
arkadaşlar ve insanın kendisini bulması
kendini kazıması kendini var etmesi bu
yollardan geçer insan olmak Bak hazır
bir oluş değildir arkadaşlar insan ona
gelen bir şeydir bana göre BV ona
gelmeye çalışmak kendimizi kazıma kendi
katmanları mızdan kendim askerlerimizden
arınmaya çalışmak gerçek bir varoluşu
gerçek oluşumunu ortaya koymanın
yollarıdır ve Burası özgürdür Burası
sonsuzdur ancak yaşamdaki statüler
kriterler tanımlanan başarılı üzerinden
tanımlanan Yollar üzerinde bu etmeye
çalıştığımız her nokta bizi belli
sınırlar içinde tutup bas kılacaktır
belirsizlik
sonsuz seçeneklerin olduğu yerdir ancak
pandemi ile birlikte birçoğumuz
belirsizliği negatif beklentiler olarak
yorumladık problem ve anksiyete olarak
yorumladık bunların dönüşmesi gerekiyor
farklı şekilde bakması gerekiyor bazen
danışanların mı şunu söyleyeyim Oo
anksiyete yönelmek Aslında içindeki
acıları hissetmemek için dışarıda bir
problem yaratmak üzere ihtiyaçtan
kaynaklanan bu anksiyete yönelmek bir
kaçış bir arkadaşım Bu dönemde bir köpek
edilmek istedi araştırdılar ettiler
böyle tam istedikleri bir köpek buldular
Başka bir şehirden getirdiler Çok tatlı
çok sağlıklı Her şey yolunda gidiyor
veteriner eve geldi aşılarını yapmaya
hiçbir sorun yok a bu işin veterinere
şunu soruyordu Ahmet Bey bizim köpeğin
burnu sürekli ıslak ve değil sürekli
dışarıda bir problem mi var acaba
Arkadaşlar bu köpeğin duası köpeğin
doğal hali bunu bile sorgulayacak kadar
bir kaybı oluşmuş olabilir içimizde Evet
şu an annem ile birlikte de başımıza
gelen nefes alışımız dans olmamızdan
dolayı bir kaygı duyacağımız kime zarar
veririz kimin nefesinden bize zarar
gelir nasıl bir sıkıntı yaşarız şeklinde
bir sıkışmışlık içerisindeyiz
bunu farketmek dışarıdaki Bu fiziksel
sorunu fark edip aslında hiçbir fiziksel
gerçeklik olmaksızın köpeğin doğasında
ki burnunun ıslaklığını dilinin dışarıda
oluşunu sorgulayacak kadar kaygılarımızı
büyük edebileceğimizi fark etmemiz ve
oradan çıkmamız gerekiyor Bu ve bu
kaygılar bir şey hizmet ediyor
e1s
saklanmaya ile hizmet ediyor Aslında
kendimizi korkularımızı gerçek
sıkıntılarımızı bulup ifade etmekten
saklanmaya sevk ediyor
yumruğun personalar ifadesiyle
tanımladığı asıl çeşitli maskeler var E
kişilik lerimizin belli bölümlerini
farklı yapılarda farklı hazneler de
duruma göre zamanı göre kişiye göre
ortaya koyarız belli bölümlerini daha
çok kullanırız belli bölümlerini daha az
kullanabiliriz Oysa bu zenginliği bu
harmanın içerisinde Açıkça ve rahat bir
şekilde var olmanın yolları var burayı
bulmak lazım ancak Burası çok zor Neden
zor Çünkü doğduğumuz andan itibaren
insan var olabilmek için öteki insana
ihtiyaç duyan bir varlık
sadece psikolojik gelişim son değil
nörobiyolojik gelişimizde ilişki
içerisinde öteki insanla birlikte var
oluyor yani annemiz babamız bizimle
ilgilenirken bakarken psikolojik
yapımızı oluşurken henüz beynimizin
yüzde yirmi beş bebeklikte 125.000
oluşta var olan bebeğin yapımızın
nörolojik bağlantılarında oluşturuyor
Yani bizim karakter yapımızı kendimize
dair
anılarımızı iç ruhsal yapımızın
fizyolojik karşılıkları oluşuyor Tabii
ki bunlar Sadece psikolojik maskelerde
yapısal maskelere dönüşmüş oluyor
bunları ayırt etmek bulmak son derece
zor ancak mümkün
TP çoğunlukla gerçek bir sorunla gelmez
danışanlar
Gerçekten içindeki acılar içindeki
sorunlar içindeki meseleyi bulmak için
gelmezler
William Rayhan ifadesini çok o Şanlı
bulurum bu noktada karakter zırh eder
Hatta yurttan daha öteye gider personel
lardan belki Aslında içimizdeki o acıyan
zorlanan gerçek varlığımızı örtmek için
çok daha kapsamlı bir dış karakter dış
kabuk oluştururuz ve onunla var oluruz
ve çoğunlukla Terapiye gelenler bu
karakter zırhında ki zedelenmeden dolayı
gelip onu konuşurken gerçek meselelerine
yavaş yavaş ulaşmaya çalışırız
bir danışanım
seansta oturuyoruz durdu etrafına
bakındı
bekliyorum sonra bana döndü Meral Hanım
burada aynı var mı
dedin Neden sordunuz dedim Çünkü şu anda
burada mıyım var mıyım Emin olamıyorum
boşluğa düşüyorum ama bir aynaya bakıp
kendimi görürsem burada olduğundan emin
olup konuşmaya devam edebilirim
konuşamıyorum sizi en başa cevapladım
Ayna karşınızda oturuyor vs size
konuşuyor durdu Evet Meral Hanım siz
buradasınız varlığınızda eminsiniz ve
beni görüyorsunuz O zaman ben de varım
diye derin bir nefes aldı insanın
varoluşunda öteki insanın kendini görüşü
Onayla yaşı kabul etmesi
balığının deliği olarak bir tanıklık
etmesini ihtiyacımız var şimdi ben
burada istediğim kadar konuşayım
istediğim gibi var olayım işte bir şey
anlatayım Sizler orada olmasanız bana
bir tepki vermezseniz herhangi bir geri
bildirim olmazsa bir süre sonra
kendimden şüphe düşüp giderek sönerim
giderek sönerim buz bu sönme lere
düşmemek için ötekine ihtiyacımız var
Ancak ötekiyle büyüdüğümüz var olduğumuz
yerde çoğunlukla bize ait olmayan
bizim özümüze t O
bizim acılarımızı sıkıntılarımızı ifade
edemeyen yapıları içselleştirilmiş
bebeklerimizin itibaren
ve Buralar çoğunlukla ifade edilemeyen
anlatılamayan bilinmeyen kırılgan ve acı
verici
Kendi öz duygularımız larımızı ifade
edilmesine izin verilmeyen alanlar olur
bu olanlar sürekli uğraşır güzel bir
yapımız var Bütün bu maskeleri rağmen
maskelerinden arınmak için Yolları yanan
uğraşan ve o yolda giden bir yapımız var
bunu sürekli arındırmaya ilave etmeye
çalışırız ancak bu kadar sosyal bir
varlık olmamıza rağmen
insana ihtiyaç duymamıza rağmen sosyal
yaşantının içerisinde ihtiyacımız olan
en temel şeylerden birisi de zarar
görmeyeceği mizi karşı taraf tarafından
Yok yok edilmeyeceğini hayatı Bir
tehlike ile karşılaşmayacaksınız ı
bilmek küçük bebek için çocuk için
psikolojik olarak yok sayılma
duygularının farkedilmemesi örselenmesi
zarar görmesi istismar edilmesi Aslında
Tüm bu tehlikeleri tehlikelerle ilgili
deneyimler oluşturuyor kayıtlar
oluşturuyor
birçoğumuz yılanlardan korkarız değil mi
bu şöyle Bir Anlamı Olmalı yılanların
yüz ifadesi yok minikleri yok tabii ki
zehirli bir canlı Tabii ki ciddi gerçek
bir tehlikesi de var Ancak köpekleri
daha çok severiz köpeklerle arkadaş
oluruz köpekler bize empatide
Duyabiliyor belli oranda Çünkü
köpeklerin mimikleri var onları tahmin
edebiliyoruz hepimizin yüz ifadeleri
özellikle ağız yapımız dişlerimiz daha
ilkel dönemlerden bakarsak birbirimize
ısırmaya canımızın gülüm Eğer bakmak
birbirimizi ısırmaya canımızın
birbirimize zarar vermeyecek misin de
göstergesidir aynı zamanda Dolayısıyla
Bu yüz ifadeleri kendimize açık olmak
maske lerimizi açmak zarar görmeden
kendimize ortaya koyabileceğimiz bir
alan içerisinde olduğumuz hissettirir ve
rahat olabiliriz ancak hepimizin o kadar
örtülü maskeleri var Farklı katmanları
var ki bu ne kadar rahat
hissedebiliyoruz ne kadar olabiliyoruz
Onu bilmiyorum bazen şey oluyor çok
sevdiğiniz birisi olur ama bir rahat
edemezsiniz yanında Bu temel o kişinin
kendi içsel kaygıları anksiyeteleri de
aramızdadır
Oo tedirginliği hissedersiniz Kimileri
gelir öyle bir enerji ile gelir ki
ruhunuz aydınlanır içinizdeki sıkıntılar
varsa unutmuşsunuz Çünkü o orada
biriktirdiği o kaygılarla ortaya
çıkmamış olur Dolayısıyla şimdi bir
takım yok artık diyoruz fiziksel olarak
bu maskelere takıyoruz ancak
bak arka planda bizi yalnız
hissettiriyor izole hissettiriyor
Bugün ilk defa açık bir konuşma
yapıyorum İki yıldır neredeyse online
eğitimler yapıyoruz bütün çalışmalarımız
online taleplerimizin birçoğu online ve
oradan maskesiz olarak görüşebilmek iyi
geliyor bir noktada ama arada yine
ekranlar var ekran koruyucular var ve bu
ekran koruyucuları mızdan kendi içimizde
de olabildiği kadar vazgeçebilmek
olabildiği kadar kurtulabilmek kendimizi
açabilmek son derece önemli umuyorum
yavaş yavaş gerçek maskeler çıktıkça
içimizdeki maskelerde çıkacak bak
terapide bu
Ama bu askerlerin
ayıklanması
Gandhi acılarımızı dışarıya aktarma
kaçmak bir yandan anlaşılmak isteriz bir
andan destek olmak isteriz ancak bir
yandan da
o da Şefkat Evet ama biraz koruma
yanyanacı Maya Belki zayıf görünme
yönelik bir şefkat ve değildir
istediğimiz
istediğimiz şey bizim ne orada
oturabilecek ve bizim bu acılarımızı tür
bir şekilde kalabilecek ve o sabitlik
içerisinde kendi sakinliği ile bize o
sakinliği aktarabilecek yapılara ulaşmak
bak oralara gelmek tabii ki o kadar
kolay değil biriyle oturup o maskeleri
kaldırmak o süreçleri açmak
bu görmeyeceksiniz tehdit altında
olmadığınızı ve kendinize
karşıtı Kendi içinizde bir tehdit
oluşturmayacak bir güvenlik hissedecek
bir seviyeye gelmek zaman istiyor Emek
istiyor Çünkü en büyük maskeleri en
büyük kısıtlamaları kendimize yapıyoruz
hayatımızın büyük çoğunluğu kendimizi
kendimizden saklamaya çalışmakla geçiyor
Aslında ikincil olarak diğer insanlardan
saklıyoruz birincil olarak hep kendimizi
örtmeye kendimizi susturmaya diğer
yönlerimizi görmemeye e fark etmeme
kabul etmeye çalışıyoruz
Oso acılardan
oradaki süreçlerden oradaki
ki kendimize ait duygular içerisinden
var olabiliriz Çünkü inşa olmak
A101 bile koy üst üste koymak gibi
değildir kendi parçalarınızı kendi
yapılarını Yapı taşlarını Emek vererek
uğraşarak bir meşgale içerisinde elde
etmek ve içeriye bakarak elde etmek
pandemi döneminde Hepimiz bir içeriye
bakmak durumunda kaldık Çünkü bu
dünyanın durduğu bu dünyanın öyle da her
zaman akmayacak mı Her ne kadar tüm
güçlü varlıklar olsak da Doğa kendimize
göre öyle olduğumuzu iddia etmiyorum tüm
güçlü varlıklar olmaya çalışıp Dünya
üzerinde bir kontrolümüz doğayı
şekillendirebilir Ece imiz
yönlendirebilecek imizi düşünüyor olsak
uzayda yaşantı arayışı içerisinde olsak
bile bir virüse teslim olacak kadar
zayıf yanlarımız olduğunu gördük ve
hepimiz içe kapandık de ve bu bize bir
fırsat verdi içimizdeki maskelere bakmak
k hem de bakmak kendimizi kendimizden
ayıklamaya çalışmak
kendimize yol olmaya çalışmak sürekli
haritalarla yola çıkıyoruz Şimdi artık
navigasyonlar var her yere navigasyon
hazır navigasyonları kurup onlarla
gidiyoruz ama yaşantımız yaşam akıntı
bakışımız kurulu navigasyonu üzerinden
olmasın
haritasız yollara çıkalım kendimiz
planını çizdiğimiz bize göre ve
kendimizi de baştan kısıtlı ayıp bu
olacak dediğimiz bir yere gitmemek bu
olacak dediğimiz yerde bütün seçenekleri
güzelde edebiliyoruz bunun olmasını
istiyorum bunu arzu ediyorum ama o
sırada etrafta neler oluyor Başka ne
yapabilirim bütün bunlara bakmak ve
kendi varoluşu muzu
kendimize ait kendimizin Dizayn ettiği
eşsiz desen imizi bütün acılarımızla
bütün var alışımız da ortaya çıkarıp çok
keyif her yere varabiliriz bu yorum
maskeler havayı diyerek başka bir
devreye geçebiliriz hep beraber Teşekkür
ederim dinlediğiniz için Hint